[Music]
in this populist moment conservatives
should champion and knew their basic
values principles and priorities and the
economic policies that flow from them
these commitments advance a particular
vision of society in which free markets
for-ward individual initiative public
policy advances opportunity and energy
and dynamism characterized our economic
lives it's a society that demands
personal responsibility self-reliance
and self-discipline but also recognizes
human imperfection in uncertainty and
therefore allows no one to fall too far
and it's a society in which mediating
institutions most especially the family
are strong and vibrant specifically
conservatives should not retreat from
their long-held policy views on the
importance of economic growth free trade
entitlement reform and friendliness to
immigrants the Conservatives should also
update their agenda to address low rates
of workforce participation sluggish wage
growth a health care sector in need of
reform failing schools and much more
conservatives should remember that
limited energetic government has a
positive role to play in a properly
ordered society empowering individuals
to earn their own success to realize
their potential and lead lives of
dignity how do you think that gonadal
policy should respond to populism let us
know in your comments also let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI